foreign
[Music]
let's go
2012 delibor from the Czech Republic
good luck to Libor and we have another
Sicilian and we have faced virtually no
open Sicilians this is this is a plague
on Humanity everybody's going Knight C3
now it's crazy
and we've already faced this move like
three or four times but hey this is a
realistic cross-section of what people
play nowadays opening Fashions change I
feel like even like two three years ago
open Sicilian was you know everybody was
playing it and the people who weren't
were playing the elephant now people are
going for all sorts of Knight C3
variations we're going to respond with a
move that I talked about
uh previously rather than going Knight
C6 and the downside of Knight C6 is that
it allows this incredibly tricky
sideline Bishop B5 we've already faced
the sideline I've gotten into trouble
against it and around that time I talked
about the immediate G6 which is very
uncommon but it sidesteps a lot of
annoying lines if white is a Grand Prix
attack player then it doesn't really
matter what you play you can play Knight
C6 or G6 our opponent is a Grand Prix
attack player which is Knight C3
followed by F4 the Grand Prix attack is
one of the most dangerous systems
against the Sicilian I haven't refreshed
my own theory in a long time so this is
going to be really fun let's see if we
can avoid getting checkmated first
things first let's fiancado our Bishop
and usually white plays Knight F3 and in
this position we have several different
setups essentially we can start by
playing D6 or we can start with a more
conventional Knight to C6 let's play
more conventionally with Knight C6
and Bishop C4 is the old school move the
new school move is Bishop to B5 this is
a more positional way of playing the
Grand Prix attack Bishop C4 is the sort
of old school method where you're aiming
directly at F7 and you can watch my
previous videos for more of a background
on the Grand Prix attack because this is
a high level higher level game
um I'm gonna skip straight to the sort
of juice and talk about the moves
themselves afterward we'll do a little
bit of a little bit more theoretical
investigating okay so as far as I know
the most popular setup and this was
popularized many decades ago is what was
taught to me as the botvinic setup and
that is where you go E6 and then you put
the Knight on E7 it's essentially like
fiancado Knight on E7 Knight on C6 and
you can do it with white as well this is
a setup this is a system not necessarily
a specific setup against a particular
opening E6 as far as I remember there's
this very dangerous Gambit line where
white response ones with D4 so there's a
lot of theory associated with the move
E6 and because I haven't refreshed my
knowledge in a long time I'm inclined to
play a slightly more modest move maybe
we can start with D6 and then we can
either play E6 or we can play a line
that I introduced a couple of speedrun
games ago where we bring our Knight
actually out to H6 this is an also
interesting line against the Grand Prix
attack
let me think about what we want to do
here so E6
I don't really want to play but we can
we can start with D6 and then play E6
that's totally possible let's do that
let's start with D6
and now that we have opened up our
Bishop one thing that we don't want to
do here is Play Bishop G4 this is a
terrible move that walks right into this
very well-known tactic Bishop takes F7
check followed by Knight G5 so
definitely not Bishop G4 we can play
Knight F6 but it was taught to me very
long time ago that you want to avoid
bringing your knight out to F6 in the
Grand Prix attack and in the closed
Sicilian I'll talk a little bit more
about that after the game I think E6 is
a much safer option uh and it's an
option that makes it more difficult for
white to jump start his uh King side
attacks so let's let's go E6 Knight H6
maybe is a move here but with the bishop
already out on C4 there's also by the
way the move Knight A5 I've seen this
move played sometimes Knight A5 in order
to kick the bishop away from this
diagonal so it should make logical sense
that you won't you would want to do that
because F7 is our weakest Pawn
well let's go E6 let's let's play more
conventionally in this game I'm
definitely out theoried okay D4 this is
uh this is getting a little disturbing
because D4 here I'm not too familiar
with so basically I'm on my own and this
is where I might get crushed if I do
okay but we're gonna try to use General
opening principles to figure out our way
out of this opening okay so the idea of
D4 is to blast open the center and as
far as I remember after C takes D4 white
responds with Knight to B5
uh this is a very dangerous line and we
could get in trouble here after CD4
white plays Knight B5 and then white is
exerting pressure on D6 but the main
idea is that if we respond with a move
like A6 white takes the pawn on D4 okay
and once the D file is opened the D6
Pawn is quite a bit weaker it's easier
to attack now I don't think we have much
of a choice here we have to take this
Pawn maybe we could also take it with
the Knight but I don't really see a
reason to give up our well-developed
Knight I think we should start with C
takes D4 and now we should invest a
little bit of time so
one thing that I really don't want to do
is play A6 because what is White's next
move likely to be well likely it's going
to be Knight takes D4 anyway so I think
A6 is I wouldn't say a waste of time
entirely but I would prefer to invest
the tempo that we have into a developing
move and there's only one logical
developing move the the reason we played
E6 is in order to pave the way for
Knight G2 E7 and I think that that's
what we should do let's go Knight G7
obviously our opponent's still in theory
so I don't like facing prep that's this
extensive Bishop B3 okay
I understand why he did this though the
point of Bishop E3 is to take the sting
out of the move D5 which we were sort of
threatening now D5 can be met with E5 of
course the bishop is no longer hanging
and I don't want to play D5 E5 because
that creates big dark square holes both
in the center and on the king side I
don't love D5 it's a move that we would
play if we were desperate
I think that we can essentially continue
developing
so I don't see a compelling reason that
we shouldn't Castle kingside
I mean again we could play A6 but I
don't really see the reason to do that
yeah I think we should just Castle
and let's see how white responds
and this is very extensive preparation
by our opponent so big big Kudos okay so
now we have a position that I know a
little bit better because this is
essentially an open Sicilian type
structure you can compare this to an
accelerated Dragon the biggest
difference is that here our Knight is on
E7 here we have a pawn 96 and both of
those things don't occur that often in
the accelerated but by and large in
terms of the structure in the center and
the fact that D4 has been played we have
a more similar type of position to the
open Sicilian now how are we going to
proceed
okay well first of all we have the
option to trade Knights which could be
good could be bad it's hard to say
so we could trade and then bring the
other night out to C6 very typical idea
in a lot of different Sicilian
structures that's one option
another option is to basically play it
more slowly but I'm worried that white
will play F5 I'm really worried about
this move F5 which could really cause
problems on our King side
so there is Queen B6 there is Queen B6
but then white plays Bishop E3 and our
Queen really looks dumb on B6 another
move that we could turn to is Knight to
A5 maybe it's a good time to play Knight
A5 and get rid of this bishop in order
to take the sting out of the move F5
which otherwise could be really really
really scary
so I actually kind of like the look of
Knight A5 yeah let's try Knight A5 and
hopefully this will finally take our
opponent out of theory
what I like about Knight A5 is it
doesn't it's not a very committal move
so we can chill on A5 as long as we need
to and then at the right moment we could
take the bishop on B3 obviously like
Bishop A4 is a super awkward move and
that Bishop could be targeted with a6b5
so I'm not worried that White's Gonna
Keep the bishop
I'm not really worried about Knight B5
that would be a really bad move because
of Queen B6 check it would send the
Knight back to D4 where we could pick it
off with the movie five
so I'm anticipating a developing move
like Bishop E3 and then we can breathe a
little bit easier because I know I won't
get checkmated
no Alan Philip Queen B6 and E5 would not
have worked because there was this move
Knight D4 to F5 classic trick I'll show
that after the game I'll write it down
actually
okay so what is going to be our kind of
system of development well when I look
at this position the bishop on C8 really
needs to be deployed and I think the
best spot to deploy it is to B7 right I
mean we could go Bishop to D7 but then
our Pawn on D6 gets even weaker and I
feel like if we could bring our Bishop
to B7
at least we're exerting some pressure on
White Center so here I would not rush
with Knight takes B3 because we could
play this move
whenever we want to and of course Knight
takes B3 creates a positional concession
it opens up the a file so white will be
able to develop some pressure on our
Queen side
so I think that we should go on with V6
and prepare to complete our development
C4 okay
so C4 our opponent starts playing this
very positionally
but he's really extending himself pretty
far in the center and on the queen side
this Pawn could end up as a weakness so
we could play Bishop B7 here that would
be the standard move another move that's
on my radar is Bishop to A6 I mean if he
put a Pawn on C4 we might as well try to
attack it with Bishop A6 and we also put
the Knight on A5 so it would really
justify the placement of our pieces
Bishop B7 I like because he can't play
Bishop C2 to defend the pawn C4 will
hang so Bishop B7 probably he's gonna
bring the queen up to D3
and then we could for example play Rook
CA and you know we could play this more
normally but Bishop A6 looks spicy I
really want to grab whoa okay now our
opponent has started to just pre-move if
this is still preparation I would be
absolutely shocked okay let me think
about this this is a dangerous move I I
forgot that F5 is a thing now that we
moved our Bishop away from C8 so what do
we do here we could grab the pawn on C4
we could definitely grab this Pawn
that would attack the bishop so white
would have to respond to that and if
white would take our Knight then we
would take White's Bishop we would be
attacking The Rook on F1
and once The Rook moved we could play
something like E5 in order to close down
the center and go after white F5 Pawn so
I don't see a compelling reason that we
can't take on C4 F takes E6 would block
would blunder the bishop on E3 with a
fork that doesn't seem dangerous
I'm gonna call White's Bluff I I oh
maybe bishop G5 actually wait a second
Bishop G5 might be annoying because that
threatens Pawn F6 wait wait Bishop G5 is
a is a problem there so let's think
about this takes Bishop G5
we could play H6 there but then there's
Knight C6 note no this is this is bad
uh so maybe we should play the immediate
E5
maybe we should play the immediate E5
but then there's still Bishop G5 amazing
okay Bishop takes C4 same problem
I just have to think about this for a
little while
okay let's go E5 let's go E5 and try to
kick the Knight out of D4 if the Knight
moves back then I'll be really happy
because then we can just take on F5 and
of course our King side is compromised
but it's not that easy for a white to
Checkmate us here with the bishop
sitting on G7
and our piece is clustered around the
center I think we'll be fine Knight B5
Okay g takes F5 Maybe
I don't want to take this Knight and
open up the diagonal for White's Bishop
we can do that whenever we want to
so G takes F5 Knight takes D6 is chaotic
but chaotic is good we want chaotic here
okay let's play GF let's play GF for now
because otherwise you know that pawn on
F5 is a huge problem for us and we're
down to six minutes our opponent with
over 15 minutes left this is incredible
very very deep knowledge of this opening
by white
yeah I don't know exactly what we're
gonna do if he takes on D6 this is just
a very hard position to wrap our heads
around and
don't feel like it's easy for me to wrap
my head around it it's just chaotic so
basically in such positions the first
person to blunder loses we're just gonna
try to avoid blundering and play logical
moves
yeah finally our opponent is out of prep
which is good I mean we're almost mated
here but that's okay
we'll survive
we will survive cue the Gloria Gaynor
song
okay so what what are we expecting here
well there's there's many ways for white
to play in the Grand Prix attack
traditionally the way that you're
recommended to meet she takes F5 is by
trying to stick the queen on H5 so from
that perspective Knight G5 may seem
terrifying but it wasn't I don't think
it was Knight takes D6 all right so what
I what I like here is the move F4 I
think that we should try to dry up the
king side as much as possible because
that's gonna buy us a little bit of time
that we could use to kind of untangle
and coordinate our pieces a little bit
better so so to me F4 is a bit of a
no-brainer because we hit the bishop we
create a little bit of a defensive a
defensive you know bull work on the king
side that'll make it harder for white to
infiltrate and we buy ourselves a Tempo
and white was obviously threatening in
this position to play e takes F5 that is
a pawn that we did not want to give up
because that's a pawn which protects our
King
so let's start with F4
and after the bishop moves away
after the bishop moves away
we have to decide how to address the
problem of this Knight on D6 which is
right in my grill it's pissing me off
this Knight is pissing me off I want to
address this night
now we have two fundamental ways that we
can try to get rid of this night we
could try to trade it or we could try to
hit it with our pieces and if we want to
hit it with our pieces the best way I
think to do that is to try to get a rook
to d8 because the queen alone is not
exerting sufficient pressure
so after Bishop F2 which I'm expecting
we could consider a move like Queen to
C7 in order to get the Rook to d8 okay
that's a reasonable move it also puts
more pressure on the C4 Pawn Yeah the
downside of flank Queen C7 is that the
Knight could return to B5 with Tempo and
hit the queen
but then we've accomplished our aim and
the queen could tuck itself away on
let's say B7 Maybe
and then we could bring a rook to d8
anyway and start getting our pieces into
the game
another thing I would point out a move
that I really would like to play at some
point is Knight E7 to G6 just as a you
know just as a way to solidify the E5
pawn and to to you know bring a little
bit more beef to the king side but I
don't want to play this move when the
Knight is still sitting on D6 and the
reason why is I don't want to give away
the Outpost on F5 for whitesnine that is
a very nasty Outpost in most positions
this one included so Knight G6 is I'm
making a mental note to myself to make
that move a little bit later When the
Smoke Clears
but right now we're gonna keep our
Knight on E7 to protect the F5 square
and to protect the D5 Square against you
know a move like Queen to D5 and stuff
like that by the way if if after Bishop
F2 we wanted to trade the Knight on D6
we could do that with this retreating
move Knight A5 to B7 which is not a move
that I would really discount easily
Knight B7 is a good positional move
we're getting rid of our opponent's
strongest piece in the events of the
trade our Bishop moves back to B7 and
puts pressure on e4 I like that
after Knight to B7 white could decline
the trade by dropping his Knight back to
B5
then our Knight on B7 is a little bit
awkward but maybe we could bring it
around to C5 so that's another option
that we could explore a lot of you are
asking about Knight G5 here I I'm
skeptical about Knight G5 because I
don't see what it does
after Knight G5 I feel like we could
even just play H6
and in that position maybe you're scared
of Queen H5 but I think we could just
take the Knight on G5 the big problem
for white is that he doesn't have the
services of his Bishop if there was no
Pawn on e4 then the bishop could move
back to C2 and exert serious pressure on
H7 I feel like the queen and the Knight
alone just aren't fast enough also we've
taken the Rook largely out of commission
by building up this Pawn chain so Knight
G5 we might face but I I'm not too
scared of it and I'm scared of most
things so
I don't think this is gonna work
yeah of course after H thinks white
could play Knight takes F7 and then we
would play Rook takes F7 Knight takes F7
we might even snap the Queens off the
board and then we would recapture the
Knight on F7 and we would have what
would we have we would have two pieces
for the rook and our minor pieces are
quite well placed like our pieces on A5
and A6 are doing a job right they're
attacking C4 so I'm fine with an end
game here I'm fine with the queens
getting off the board our pieces are not
poorly placed
well because if white ever plays C5 then
we could take on B3 remember that right
that's why we put our Knight on A5 to to
really take the sting out of a move like
C5
he disconnected I don't think so I think
our opponent is just thinking there's a
lot to think about here
there's a lot to think about here for
white I would play Bishop F2 pretty
quickly 95 I saw this move I knew that
this existed I wasn't taking it very
seriously maybe I should have
so let's let's try to deconstruct this
move what what on Earth is is happening
here
what on Earth is happening here
so two pieces are hanging that's the way
I see it there's the bishop on E3 and
there's the Knight on E5 either of them
can be captured we could also take on B3
but forget about forget about that for
now
my intuition and probably yours is the
same tells me to take on E5
because that's the problem piece but
let's actually try to calculate if we
instead take on E3
I would imagine that White's idea is to
play Knight takes F7
okay Knight takes F7 what if we just
move our Queen there
what's the big whoop I guess the big
whoop is that white plays C5
and opens up a line of fire toward our
King and if we take on B3 then white
takes back with a queen and is
threatening all sorts of shenanigans
FV Knight takes F7 we could play takes
F7 Rook takes up seven
and in that position
might be able to throw in the move E2
okay I need to think about this
carefully
because I I think I've understood his
idea after Bishop takes E5
which I think is just to play Bishop
takes F4 but that's not too scary Bishop
takes C5 another thing to remember is
that if white delivers a check on G4 how
should we deal with that check well we
shouldn't bring our King into the corner
because then it could get checkmated
potentially with Knight takes F7 I think
that Bishop E5 Queen G4 the beauty of
this Knight on E7 is that it could block
any check with Knight to G6
so I'm going to play this move largely
on the basis of intuition
but I calculated F take C3 just enough
to understand that the resulting
position is extremely chaotic and hard
to evaluate generally you want to avoid
such positions if you have a choice
right sometimes you don't have a choice
and it sometimes you're on the losing
side and if you're on the losing side
that's exactly what you want right you
want to create chaos here it's a little
bit easier to assess the position our
King is pretty safe Bishop takes F4 I
think is the best move so first of all
we can trade Queens if we want to we
could play Queen takes D6 here okay
then white would have to take otherwise
he's two miners down Bishop D6 Bishop D6
but obviously that resulting position is
not over white has two pawns for the
piece our pieces are kind of
discombobulated I think that we are
winning after Rook fe8 I think
technically that position is probably
going to be a win but I'd like to find
something better if at all possible the
alternative I think is to take on F4 the
rook recaptures and we play a move like
Knight to G6 to start you know to start
getting our pieces to better squares I'm
apprehensive though about leaving the
Queens on the board especially given our
time situation
so from the perspective of playing like
a Russian Schoolboy Bishop Queen takes
D6 makes sense
from the perspective of trying to be as
accurate as possible
I think probably it'll end up that
Bishop takes F4 is the best move but
again I'm trying to give you a realistic
portrayal of what I actually would play
and what I actually would play
in a real game
given the time situation this queen
takes D6 it's not a glamorous move
we're just not gonna win us any beauty
prizes but what I know is that it gets
into an end game where we are up a minor
piece and white has no clear attack
against our King anymore
and clearly I think this move was missed
by our opponent
no I take Bishop takes B2 why right why
would you need this this meaningless
pawn and give white a tempo for an
attack I'm sure the engine would
probably claim that black is still
winning after Bishop takes B2 maybe even
we could drop our Bishop back to G7
that's a move that wasn't on my radar at
all but probably should have been Bishop
G7 just simple bring the bishop back
keep an important Defender and just ask
white what on Earth you have and the
answer is basically nothing
but Queen takes D6 is you know really
the simplifying move white has to take
because Queen G4 check here is
completely innocuous we just go Knight
G6 and the attack is over
Bishop takes E5 we play Queen takes E5
we're two minor pieces up
so nothing to think about here for our
opponent I don't know what he's what
he's
going on about here
but Queen D6 Bishop D6 Bishop D6 is
pinning our Knight so how should we
defend against this pin
how should we defend against this pin
and there is a very important tactical
detail that I calculated which I haven't
told you guys about yet so how should we
how should we play this well the move is
self-evident right we want to not just
defend the night but we also want to
solve the underlying problem of the pin
so Rook F to E8 is basically automatic
now in such situations
and we encountered a very similar
position yeah that is the move that I
saw I had to see this move when I was
calculating Queen takes D6 we did
something very similar in a speedrun
game a couple games ago I'll show you
after the game Bishop A4 is scary
because it hits the Rook we can't move
the Rook because we drop the Knight on
E7 so you might say well then I have to
block on C6 but if we play Knight ec6
well you can see how awkward that is and
maybe white has the move before
but instead we have a tactic and how do
you find this tactic well what is the
drawback of the move Bishop A4 does it
actually release White's control over
anything yes there's the C4 pawn and you
should see the possibility of Knight
takes C4 as an interesting possibility
even though you don't it's hard to
calculate so Knight takes C4
if white moves the Bishop from D6 then
we can intercept White's Bishop with B5
okay
but if after Knight takes C4 white takes
the Rook which Bishop do you take and
that's an easy question right comparison
should tell you that the a bishop on D6
is the one that you want to take because
in that resulting position you're
attacking the rook and you're attacking
the bishop on E8 white can't save both
at the same time we're gonna end up in a
position where we have three minor
pieces against a rook now three minor
pieces against a queen is double-sided
three minor pieces Against The Rook in
most cases is an overwhelming amount of
material for the minor pieces even in an
end game where the Rooks often benefit
even in an end game where the Rooks
often benefit
Okay so
this is winning for black
Bishop takes C4 I didn't like as much
Bishop takes E4 maybe works
actually maybe we can squeak by with
that move but I didn't like it
and I'll show you after the game
so Knight takes C4 was a critical detail
missed by our opponent
Bishop takes E8 Knight takes D6 and
another important detail is that F7 is
protected by our Knight
so Bishop takes F7 check would have
released the Bishop from our clutches
but we just take it with our Knight in
fact I would do that with white I think
that's the only way that he can get you
know a pawn for the piece
but then we have
three minor pieces for a rook and two
pawns which is not over right the game
is not over there we would have to
demonstrate some technique but I think
black is winning
what if Bishop B4 will then B5
toxic appians then B5
Bishop before we play B5
and we're chilling
and that's of course something that you
have to see also which is that when you
eliminate the pawn and you should ask
yourself that question whenever you
eliminate a bond or a piece you know
what was that pawner piece actually
doing what was it controlling and when
you ask yourself that question sometimes
you you discover that well certain Pawn
breaks or certain moves are now possible
in the absence of that pawner piece
okay so it's just something that you
always want to get into the habit of
doing particularly if it's an important
Pawn or piece one that's in the center
one that's controlling a lot of squares
what new resources are possible then
anybody should be able to see B5
our opponent is exhausting most of his
time I don't know what for I mean Bishop
E8 is largely forced
what's funny is that if white moves no
actually Bishop before yeah B5 we would
have to untangle our pieces there but it
would not be too difficult to do that
the power of simplification
yeah so Bishop E8 Knight D6 Bishop takes
F7 check Knight takes F7 then White's
going to move the Rook probably up to F3
and then our next project will be to
coordinate our minor pieces so that they
are actually all working together and
defending each other
and in that resulting position what we
would have to prevent is kind of The
Rook infiltration to the seventh rank
because Rooks are stronger than minor
pieces when they're able to gain kind of
Maximum activity
okay Bishop B4 I'm relieved to see that
move I think it's easier for black to
win in this position
so now we play B5 that's a no-brainer
intercepting the bishop and now next
step for us is to consolidate and
consolidating that's a word that a lot
of people misunder it basically just
means you have a situation where your
pieces are kind of scattered around the
board and they're not well coordinated
can we bring those pieces onto good
squares such that they're working
together uh etc etc now here there's an
interesting moment because you might
notice that the Rook is x-raying the E4
Pawn I think a lot of you are probably
thinking let's go Knight C6 after Knight
C6 the bishop will drop back to C3 and
if we take the pawn on e4 I'm a little
bit apprehensive about the move Rook to
F3 in that position and white tries to
lift The Rook up to G3 and this bishop
on C3 is controlling the retreating
Square on h8 if black can send us if our
opponent can send us in the direction of
f8 well maybe that's a little bit a
little bit scary in time pressure
so let's see if we can find anything
safer
I think there is a safer option which is
not to play Knight C6 but to play Knight
to G6 I want a little bit I want a
bodyguard on the king side just to make
sure that there's no shenanigans that
are awaiting us on the on the G file
does that make sense let's go Knight G6
Rook F3 yeah our opponent was
basically waiting to pre-move that I
guess we should have played Knight to C6
because that would have won the bishop
let's think about this for a second
if we play Rook takes E4 there is the
move Rook F1 that's a little bit
annoying actually
that is a little bit annoying
but I think we have a winning tactic
there
I think we have a winning tactic there
yeah I think we can play rookie four
I think we can grab this Pawn now what
do I see
when we play Rook takes E4 well what I
see what is the rook and E4 doing well
again x-rays x-rays x-rays super
important and here you should see that
the Rook is x-raying the bishop
now what does that tell us well that
tells us that if we move the Knight
we'll be attacking
the bishop on before but it is scary to
move the Knight because it also opens up
the line of fire to the F7 Pawn so we
have to move the Knight on such a square
such that we take the sting out of the
move Bishop takes F7 check of course we
play Knight E5
of course we play 95. there is a
slightly scary option though that I
missed there must be a way out yeah
there is a way there is a way for us to
keep our extra piece if our opponent
does this then I'll mention it
no Rook F7 I saw Rook F7 we play Knight
F7
and basically we're up a rook Rook F7
Knight F7
Bishop F7
King G7
yeah I allowed this to get complicated
this was this was uh very sloppy by me
and I think there is a way for white to
make this super complicated
but this is going to take a little bit
of GM Magic
yeah no this was
we should have just played we should
have just played rook d8 and again this
is the lack of prophylaxis I was
impatient this is a very instructive
mistake because I got impatient I wasn't
willing to invest exactly two more moves
and then there would be no threats and
we could just proceed and bring the
bishop back and win the game easily no I
had to play rookie four and I missed
this Knight F7
we have to trade take on F7
and now we bring the king up to G7
and what I saw
was that if button yeah crap our phone
has found everything here
okay
being H6
King H6 we have to go there
and this is where I missed the move I
calculated up to this point I did
calculate up to this point and the only
thing that I saw was Bishop to D5 this
is what I saw
and after Bishop to D5 what we
essentially can do is say okay we're
going to lose one of our Rooks but we
can connect the Rooks so that if white
takes the Rook we take the bishop and
then we're up a minor piece and we're
finally essentially Home Free
then we're finally I mean it's still
it's still not that easy to convert
because our Bishop is terrible
but that I think we will be able to win
we also have B4 yeah B4 is definitely a
resource to keep in mind
but this is going to get very very dicey
if white finds the right move here which
I won't mention but
not that I'm suspecting a opponent of
anything of stream sniping obviously 100
not
actually wait a second there's a crazy
idea
oh my God it might actually work I need
to calculate it
wildly difficult to calculate in time
pressure
there is a beautiful idea that we have I
could have played it on this move I
could have played it on this move so the
move that I'm scared of that I didn't
see is Bishop back to D2 check that's
the move I failed to anticipate Bishop
D2 check I only saw Bishop D5
I only saw Bishop D5
and then I think we're fine steal it
still it's dicey still it's dicey in
that position but I think we'll be able
to win
but the move that I missed was Bishop D2
check why is it so scary because King H5
is terrifying in that position we could
get mated there Rook F5 check maybe it's
mate maybe it's not but it's scary
so after Bishop D2 check if we go back
to G7 white just keeps repeating moves
Bishop D2 Bishop C3 and we can't go back
to f8 that's another big problem because
then we walk right into a discovered
attack and white wins all of our pieces
there is an idea okay yeah let me think
okay
well let's repeat moves once that's not
gonna hurt that's not gonna hurt
it's definitely not gonna hurt
okay I think I might have figured out a
brilliant win
but it hinges on
basically move for move calculation so
if I'm wrong we're worse okay I don't
know what our opponent is thinking about
because Bishop C3 is absolutely forced
Bishop C3 is absolutely forced
and then my idea is to play Knight E5
which itself is not a surprising move
for people I think 95 but after Bishop
D5 I think we might have a crazy
resource let's give it a shot let's give
it a shot 95
so
95 is a logical move but it seems to
fail to Bishop D5 and it appears that
we're losing the game there because
we're losing all of our pieces
after Bishop D5 but there I think I
found a resource that involves
identifying the X-ray against the white
Rook on F1 and playing what move
what am I what do I have my eye on here
yeah B4
which leads to Absolute chaos because
now both everything is hanging
everything except the bishop on D5 is
now hanging oh we found Rook F7
but wait a second Rook F7
is not scary I think because we have to
go up to where do we go let me think
about this
we have to go to G6 I think King G6 is
the critical move
yeah I saw this King G6
and if white takes on e4 okay wait
there's no way this move works
or does it oh my God what is happening
here wait a second
no I don't think this works because I
think we can just play BC
no it's still complicated there
or can we play Knight F3 check can we
play Knight F3 check
gf3 rookies yeah Knight F3 wins
Knight F3 just wins the game
and I did I almost didn't see this move
it comes out of nowhere you wouldn't
think that there's like a discovery
against whites King that ends the game
but there is
well the positive news is that we will
have some very exciting analysis to do
this is going to be really fun
yeah Knight F3 check wins because Pawn
takes F3 everybody should
be able to calculate the resulting line
we play Rook take C7 white takes the
Rook on A8 we take the bishop on C3 and
we are up a full rook in that resulting
position okay not a hard line to
calculate
the moment and how did I see it well
because I looked at the position with
kind of a fresh pair of eyes I'll tell
you what I was fixated on before the
moment I took a step back and like asked
myself can I make any other observations
like do can I see anything else
interesting about this position that's
the moment I spotted that there's a
connection a standoff between the Rooks
but this is the importance of taking the
broader perspective I can see according
to the engine that BC is also winning
but it's a lot less convincing
okay so I propose that we start let's
start from the start and let's be
patient I want to look at the opening
first and then we will get to the end
game pretty quickly I won't take too
long on the opening but this is an
opening related speed run so I want to
do at least a little bit of theoretical
analysis every game
all right so I'm going to pull up chess
base
and uh Grand Prix has given me some
problems the Grand Prix attack I think
is one of the best anti-sicilians along
with the elephant and I I think a lot of
title players and a lot of good players
just don't really study it uh that that
seriously even though it's you know it
is a very serious opening it is a very
serious opening so E4 C5 Knight C3 you
play G6
now
we have played this move once before and
I distinctly remember in that speedrun
we talked about a move that tries to
essentially exploit the drawback of the
move G6 what is a move that white has
which tries to specifically capitalize
on the fact that black hasn't gone
Knight C6
and this may seem like a very scary move
but it we analyzed it and it's not bad
for black yeah so D4 right and after CD
Queen D4
if I mean clearly you're punished for
the night not being on C6 and we
analyzed this line Knight F6
and if white plays E5 this is very
important to remember black plays Knight
C6 with Tempo this is the critical
resource and black is okay here I
remember us analyzing this position
so instead of E5 white is best advised
to play
you know Knight F3 or something like
that
but
black is doing fine here this is
essentially a dragon-like position this
is a dragon-like position where white is
slightly better according to the engine
I think Duda Carlson had this I won't
analyze this again you can find this in
the previous video where we had this
line
in the game white plays the Grand Prix
attack F4 so Bishop G7 Knight F3 Knight
C6 here white is that a further
Crossroads as far as I remember uh there
is Bishop B5 which we've already faced
in this game we Face the old school move
which is still very very dangerous
Bishop C4 so let's see what the top guys
actually do here let's see what the best
way for black to handle this actually is
because I don't think it's the way that
I played
okay so according to the engine E6 and
D6 are both legitimate moves
so we can go with D6 for now and if we
don't like what we see we can take a
look at E6 so D6 castles E6
computer gives equality tiny Edge for
black which it always does in the Grand
Prix attack and white plays this very
risky but very dangerous move d4
so here we responded correctly the move
is C takes D4
white plays Knight to B5 black plays
Knight cheetah E7
and according to the engine at least at
a lower depth the computer actually does
like the move A6 but it also likes
Knight G7 it gives equality here Bishop
to B3 is correct
so this is theory
and castles is correct
Knight B takes D4 Knight A5 is the top
move okay so I can improvise on my feet
this is the top Engine line with Knight
A5
and it's along with a couple of other
lines which the computer assigns is
equal 0.00 there are still games in the
database there are still games in the
database 23 games including some Grand
Master games after Bishop E3
now we played B6 still games in the
database
but B6 it likes a little bit less it
still gives it as equal
okay so I think B6 is normal
and C4 is not a novelty it was played in
2022 by a Grandmaster Lars Oscar hauga
against another Grandmaster in a
tournament in Iceland it was played by
two Icelandic Grandmasters so clearly
this is still preparation and Bishop A6
was played in that game oh my God Bishop
A6 was played and our opponent played
the best move F5 is an improvement is an
improvement over the move that was
played in the game which is Knight to B5
this was played in The Grand Master game
and ip5 is a very serious mistake it's a
blunder
can anybody tell me why Knight B5 is a
blunder our opponent I mean absolute
Kudos he knew everything here
he knew this very very deeply why is
Knight B5 a horrible blunder
and black responded correctly in the
game
but lost the game actually black lost
the game but responded correctly it's
already minus two yeah D5 simply simply
D5 and this Knight is in huge trouble I
mean the C4 Pawn gets undermined
in the game white played Queen E2 and
here D takes C4
was played but that's a big mistake
apparently according to the engine
you're supposed to trade everything and
then play de4 trade everything and then
win the pawn and if white plays Knight
to G5
black has even Queen to D3 is very very
strong and obviously this is a disaster
so this is not acceptable for white and
our opponent improving on the game and
get F5 gives white a pretty big
Advantage according to the engine so
Bishop A6 is actually the first mistake
of the game everything up to that point
was normal what black is supposed to do
here is in fact go Bishop to B7
and the difference is that after F5
you're supposed to go
EF5 EF5
and now you justify the placement of the
bishop by striking in the center with D5
this is the point of locating the bishop
on B7 now we will check why the same
thing is not as applicable with the
bishop on A6 that's called the method of
comparison that's where you really get
to the bottom of why the engine
recommends what it does but first let's
have a look at this very complicated
position
so what moves would you play here with
white I want to see what the chat thinks
white should do here what are some moves
that we should look at here from Black's
perspective
yeah Bishop G5 is my instinct Bishop G5
is my instinct because it threatens F6
that's a nasty move I also think we
should look at CD I don't like CD I
think CD is bad for white yeah it is bad
for white because you take the bishop
and opening up the center favors the
side with the better Bishops in this
case it's black
and after a takes B3 Knight takes D5 I
mean obviously black is totally fine
here Bishop G5 and simply Knight F6
and black is black is Home Free
so white doesn't want to take that pawn
that would be very short-sighted
instead Bishop to G5 is one of the top
engine moves
and black has to find and only move here
Queen up to D6
obvious move to prevent F6 you have to
prevent F6
the funny thing is if instead you try to
take the bishop first White plays F6
anyway this is the reason you have to go
Queen D6 and white threatens to take
both of these pieces
so apparently you have to go Queen D6
Knight to B5 is not scary because black
has a check on C5
super important detail
the engine line is crazy Queen to E1
attacking the Knight again
now black has several moves but one of
them is to take on D4 holy smokes
why would you give up the dark squared
Bishop who can find the right follow-up
here
like you almost never do this in the
Sicilian the only reason you do this is
if you have something incredibly
concrete if you have a specific tactic
then you take on D4
who can spot the follow-up move no the
follow-up has to be something specific
it can't just be rookie a then why did
you give up your Bishop
right it has to be something concrete it
is D takes C because the Knight on D4 is
undefended
the Knight on D4 is undefended
because the point is if white plays
Bishop E7 then you play Queen takes D4
check and then you can take the other
Bishop
so white has to defend this Knight at
all costs with Rook to D1
no this is crazy now you play F6 it's
equal 0.00 Bishop F4 only move Queen D5
only move threatening Checkmate Rook F2
only move defending against mate take
the bishop 96.
line is still continuing and it's only
moves for both sides here this is engine
analysis Queen E4
rookie 2 only moves every other move
would lead to an advantage for either
side Queen F5 Knight f8
Knight D5 only move
Bishop D6 Knight C4
Queen H4 only move it's leading to a
draw just you wait takes Queen H7
and it's a Perpetual check check
because the king can't cross the E file
this is the Sicilian ladies and
gentlemen
and and this is why people are asking
why is it hard to make a course on the
Sicilian or a course in general
I mean this is the reason because of
lines like this
this is a ridiculous Engine line and it
all starts it's normal until Bishop
takes D4 this is what causes the
pandemonium
now black has Alternatives here to
Bishop takes D4 there is the more
conventional move Rook 88 although the
position is no less crazy
because here the line goes Knight B5
Queen C5 check Bishop E3 now another
ridiculous engine move Knight takes up
five
giving up the queen capturing the queen
but giving up an exchange apparently
black has full compensation for the
exchange here uh because your Bishop is
a beast and because you have a pawn
cd5 you take the bishop and then you
take the pawn and this is equal
because the Bishops are really
crisscrossing the board and offer black
sufficient compensation so in a game I
would play Bishop D4 because that's too
sexy of a move not to play
so that is the simple reason why Bishop
B7 is the best move in the position
yeah I mean who I don't even really
think I had to show this this is this is
basic Betty right here but it's amazing
to me that our opponent's knowledge of
this opening extended past Theory like
C4 one game in the database recent game
so this was clearly White's preparation
and he improved on the play of a GM so
now let's understand what the difference
is after Bishop A6 F5 and the question
that you want to ask yourself is this
what happens if black plays in exactly
the same way that you would after Bishop
B7 that's how you get to the bottom of
why a certain move is better than
another one so the question is after ef
ef why can't we play the move D5
like what's the actual reason
so apparently according to the engine
the reason consists in the move Knight
to G5 this is the refutation
now you might tell wait a second well
why wasn't Knight G5 a thing after
Bishop B7 does that process make sense
so let's look at Knight G5 here and then
we'll look at it with the bishop on A6
and eventually we're going to understand
what the critical difference is if you
play Knight G5 here black plays DC
so now we go back to the other line
now we go back to the other line and we
we check DC here
um we check DC here
so if DC here then black white plays FG
and if black plays HG
then Queen G4 leads to checkmate now we
go back to the other line Y is FG not
good there
so Knight G5 dcfg
I I hope what I'm doing actually like
makes sense
we're just comparing the placement of ah
and this is the point where black has an
additional resource see it's pretty easy
if you know the process to follow now
who can tell me let's see if anybody can
use logic to figure this out what could
possibly be the virtue of having the
bishop on B7 what could possibly be an
additional resource that solves Black's
problems here
yeah it's Queen T5
it's Queen D5 because the only thing you
can do with that Bishop is threaten
Checkmate and apparently this move
allows black to throw a spanner in the
works white isn't able to attack
properly because of the mate threat if
white goes here
then you go H5 just deflecting the queen
if GF you can of course take with the
Rook because the queen is hanging
and if the queen moves back then you can
just play Bishop takes D4 gf7 you still
play Rook F7
holy freaking smokes and after Rook F7
you again use the fact that the queen is
tied down to G2 and you take all of
White's pieces you just take everything
and you're going to take a fourth minor
piece on the next move which is also
hanging
and so that is the critical difference
with the bishop on A6 with the bishop on
A6
um you don't have this resource of Queen
D5 here so what you ultimately have to
do
is play either HG and lose after Queen
to G4 because this is Unstoppable or if
you take the bishop on B3
then you lose the game after
Queen H5 yeah why this is just
overwhelming attack here H6 is Forest GF
here oh oh there's a sexy move here
again Rook F6
threatening Rook takes H6 with Checkmate
and two moves
black has to go Knight G8
and now
just Rook G6 this is just absolutely
crushing FG is coming and there's too
many mate threats here
and that's it Knight G5 is the big
reason that you want to play the move
Bishop to B7 and that's the takeaway
from the opening in this game
hope you enjoyed that little Excursion
into the depths of Sicilian nonsense
now by the way I should point out for
the sake of completeness that after the
move B6
after the move B6 White's main move like
the most popular move
has been Queen to E1
because you're trying to get the queen
around to H4 but this is bad because of
Bishop A6 this is a bad move
and the problem this was a game between
a 2400 and a 2586 classical game
white has to play Rook F2 and then it
begs the question well then why did you
put the queen on E1 if you can't even
get it to H4 and black is better after
Knight B3 ab3 and Bishop B7
and black is white is experiencing
serious problems with the E4 Pawn this
is the game weighing against Zhao
Washington 2022 in that game white
played out five and black responded
cold-bloodedly with E5
white played Bishop G5 which is an idea
that we actually had in the game
interesting and here black responds with
H6 this is uh actually how the game
continued F6
HG FG King G7
and here white found a sick tactic but
it doesn't work Knight G5
e takes D4 Rook takes F7 check
and who can tell me how should black
respond to this move
what should black do
let's see if you understand the concept
of Queen disease properly
this is such a common type of mistake
that people make
so a lot of people's automatic reaction
would be well I can't take the Rook
because I lose my queen
but you have to always put it in context
how would How would how much are you
getting for the queen
I everybody forgets to ask this question
you actually do want to take the Rook
and after 96 King G and 98 Rook d8 black
gets a crap ton of material for the
queen you get two minor pieces in a rook
yeah white gets another Pawn on A7 true
but we can chew The Rook away with
Knight C6 and white also has this major
weakness on e4 which you can really zero
in on with rookie 8. black is much
better slash winning this is how the
game continued actually
so black was able to win the game in
this way
so C4 is an improvement over Queen E1
and over a couple of other moves that
was played in this position I also see
that Queen D3 was played but this
doesn't seem all that scary so let's get
to the game F5 we decided to play E5 the
question is where did our opponent
actually end up going wrong our opponent
ended up going wrong in this position
Knight B5 is an automatic move
and after Knight B5 already black is
doing all right it's equal but with the
best move white is plus over minus and I
saw the best move I missed it initially
I saw it ultimately
what is the best move for white same
idea that we just saw
same idea that we just saw you have to
understand how vulnerable these two
minor pieces are and you have to set up
the move F6 how do you do that
Bishop G5 Bishop G5 is best
now a couple of very important details
if black plays F6 then white has 96 so
that fails if black takes the Knight
then F6 is devastating
and you might say well I don't get why
F6 is so devastating like we just won a
piece White's winning a piece back
what's the big deal the problem isn't
that white is winning the piece back
it's which piece he's winning the
problem is we cannot keep this bishop
and you should understand intuitively
why without this bishop
there are some exceptions we saw an
exception but in most cases you cannot
survive without this bishop if you play
Bishop F6 I mean look at this position
Queen D2 Queen H6 is literally
Unstoppable literally
so that's lost and you can't keep the
bishop because white plays Fe and wins
The Rook so that's the actual reason
this move is so scary now black should
respond here with H6 and force the
bishop away
and here
white plays bishop h4g5 and let's see if
people can once again find a move that's
very much in the spirit of the Grand
Prix attack this leads to a crazy line
that I think you guys will really enjoy
but what's the move here because two
pieces are hanging
so you might think it's Knight takes G5
because that's what you're used to but
think for a second about what piece you
want to leave on the board yeah the move
is Bishop G5 compare right when you
compare this position to this position
which attacker is stronger if you ask
yourself that question well clearly this
Knight is the stronger attacker
because it combines with the queen
and here black has to find an only move
which is ridiculous impossible if black
takes then this is obviously checkmate
this is obviously checkmate
um
rookie eight you take this Pawn you go
back this is easy check and then at the
end you have mate with 96 this is pretty
Elementary patterns black has to find
Knight C5
and the logic of this move is
straightforward you're trying to
eliminate the Knight on G5 but why are
you putting the Knight on D5 well
there's a secondary reason which is that
if white plays Queen H5 then the Knight
is able to drop back to F6 and protect
H7 that's why you don't go Knight C6 or
Knight C8 or any other knight move
so after Knight C5
white finds a counter blow Knight de6
Jesus F takes E6 Knight takes E6 and
white just gets a huge attack Queen F6
and now Apparently after
Queen takes D5 it's plus over equals
it's like 0.6 finally the Smoke Clears
black plays Bishop B7 to force the queen
away Queen to D3 and white has
overwhelming compensation for the piece
there's the idea of Rook F3 Rook G3 the
Knight is a monster and at this point
white already has three pawns for the
piece
just mind-blowing complications with
Bishop G5 but this would have caught put
us in very serious trouble
this would have put us in very serious
trouble
yeah this is why chess's chess is so fun
I hope I'm not going too deep
but this is how you learn about tactics
right it's not just solving puzzles
analyzing helps you really just get to
the bottom of some of these ideas and
it's also fun it's fun to analyze with
an engine it's also fun when you have a
grand master like guiding you around
which is what I'm trying to do so after
E5 Knight B5
now we're able to take this pawn and now
black is fine now black is fine so our
opponent correctly plays Knight takes D6
finally the Smoke Clears and here Knight
E5 is the horrible move our opponent is
trying to play in the spirit of the
Grand Prix attack but he just doesn't
have enough going on the king side to
justify this pawns this night sack this
this night sack is just terrible the
correct move is Bishop F2 and according
to the engine the move that I intended
to play was best Queen C7 in order to be
able to play Rook Ada and here we were
calculating Knight G5 I was mentioning
this during the game black has to play
H6 why does black have to play H6
because if you procrastinate then this
is devastating because the maid is
threatened and now Knight F7 is
horrendous so
here you have to immediately root out
the night Knight takes F7 Rook F7 and F7
King F7 what should white play here who
can tell me how should white proceed
continue the initiative otherwise white
is much worse this is like this is a
no-brainer this move should be automatic
to you
yeah C5 very nice C5
black takes the bishop but the queen
replaces the bishop
and the benefit of the queen on B3
once the king escapes is that white can
play CB a b and maybe white could grab
that pawn or white could just move the
Rook away and the engine gives equality
here which I agree with I think it's
just a super complicated position that's
hard to evaluate and usually that means
equal so this is how the game should
have continued
but our opponent just is unable to
maintain the tension he plays Knight
takes C5 and now let's get directly to
the final stage of the game because
after Bishop E5 and queen takes D6 black
is winning black is winning this is up a
piece and I just wanted to point out
before we get to the final stage of the
game
where you saw this before so where you
saw this before
and I just realized we played this guy
once before
this is the second time we played this
guy oh it was the jababa London game
where I missed 94. so no wonder we got
into a bad position here I was in
trouble as well
so this guy uh this guy knows what he's
doing
I'm just looking for the game
yeah this is the game where you saw a
very similar tactic remember that when a
piece is defended by another piece
particularly if it's a rook or a queen
you can generally chase away the
defender so remember this game where we
first played Knight G7 and then we did
the same thing with the bishop this is
exactly what our opponent did attacked
attacked The Rook or that's exactly what
we did and if the Rook has to move then
you take the Knight now compared to this
game
we had an additional resource in this
position
which is of course Knight takes C4 and
if Bishop E8 then we play Knight D6 and
The Rook is hanging the bishop is
hanging I explained this during the game
black is winning so let's go to the game
Bishop before B5 Bishop B3 Knight G6
Rook F3 and Rook takes E4 is probably
not a mistake in itself but I think the
safer move the safer move would have
been just to bring another Rook into the
game just defend the F7 pawn and white
is out of ideas white is simply out of
ideas our next move is going to be
either Rook takes E4 or Bishop B7 we're
gonna win the E4 Pawn we're gonna win
the game so remember the power of
prophylaxis when you stop your
opponent's threats it's so much easier
to play I could not resist
because I thought that I had calculated
this accurately and it turns out that
this is a lot more complicated than I
than I made it out to be
so what happens if white plays Bishop F7
well this is easy this is easy you take
the bishop and then you take the other
bishop and you're up two minor pieces
but of course our opponent finds
something fancier than that Rook takes
F7
and this move is a lot scarier because
if you ignore the Rook then you lose the
game to Rook takes A7 check and white
will take this Rook with check and then
when the bishop as well
so our hand is forced here we have to
play Knight F7 Rick F7 Bishop F7
King G7
and now the second important moment okay
now in this position white actually had
another very interesting resource which
was the move Rook takes F7 and in order
to preserve an advantage black has to
find and only move in this position this
is a very difficult move so if you're
watching on YouTube
I highly recommend that you pause the
video and try to figure out the defense
here because it's very easy to blunder
here
most popular wrong answer
so the most popular wrong answer is Rook
takes Bishop because you might say aha
well what is White gonna do well
probably white is going to try to win
the most number of pieces right so
White's gonna take on A7 but I saw one
step ahead I'm going to take the bishop
and I'm going to win no you're not white
takes the Rook with check and then takes
the other Rook and if you don't take the
bishop and you move the king you have to
stay on the eighth Rank and the problem
is that you also lose the bishop on A6
in the end
does that make sense so if you instead
move the king to the side this also is
not going to cut it because White's
going to give you this nasty little
check on C3
and yeah you can block with 95 but just
look at this position this is a disaster
everything is being lost right now or or
white could play rookie seven and pick
up the Knight you're gonna you're gonna
lose the game here
so the correct idea is Rook to C4
cutting off slicing off the discovered
attack this is the benefit of being
upper Rook you get to give away some of
your material and here black is winning
black is up a piece now according to the
engine white preserves some practical
Chances with Rook C7 because Black's
King is so bad and Black's minor pieces
are so bad that it's really really hard
to untangle and here are the best move
is just to bring the bishop around to
the center Bishop C8 is a really strong
move and okay black will have to
demonstrate some technique but this is
winning this is winning
does that make sense
um so instead our opponent plays Bishop
F7 we have to go up Bishop C3 King H6
and Bishop D2 is the move that I missed
and according to the
according to the end I had no idea
whether we were winning or losing after
King H5 apparently black is still better
but can you really blame me for not
wanting to go for this position I mean
this is crazy
this is crazy let me run stockfish here
at a high depth and give you the best
line
stockfish at a high depth this is where
the chest.com engine really is
insufficient but positions that are this
complicated need to be looked at with a
serious engine
so apparently
here's the evaluation just a second the
evaluation is an advantage no it's equal
oh my God but this is insane this is
impossible apparently the best move here
is not to give this check but instead to
play Bishop D5
so just to make sure we're on the same
page how should black respond to this
move how should black response to Bishop
D5
just to make sure everybody understands
what's going on here yeah Rook 88 right
Rook 88 now there is an only move if
anybody finds this move in a game you
immediately call the TD or you you call
Danny wrench literally
literally apparently the best move there
is a move that keeps equality which is
just to take and go Rook F7 and win all
of Black's pawns but the absolute best
move is H3
H3
and the idea is to take away the g-force
Square from Black's King that's the idea
so if black moves The Rook then there's
Checkmate in three moves check
mate that's the idea Black's King is
caught in something like a mating net
here
and black can draw with King H4
and now white plays Bishop E4 rookie for
Rook F5 Black's King is still in serious
trouble
but there is a Perpetual check King G3
check King H4 and we have a repetition
of moves black can't do anything else
here because if instead you play a move
like Bishop C8
you get checkmated check and this is the
secondary idea of H3 now white has G4
and you have to give up your rook and if
you go the other way you get checkmated
so yeah so it was a good call for me not
to go King H5 in long story short
so I decided to apply the final idea
knighty5 and without this idea this game
would have been a draw because without
this move and I played correctly
apparently this is still equal but white
has to be super precise
so let me tell you what I calculated
with this move 95. oh my gosh I
calculated the
oh my okay this is this is a okay this
is amazing this is amazing you're gonna
enjoy this tremendously this is
beautiful
this is beautiful okay
Get Ready Get Ready Get ready so okay
first of all let's make sure we're on
the same page what is the point of 95
well the point is that the King has
nowhere to go because if you go back to
f8 you get you can Master credit Bishop
D5 or Bishop G6 even better
we've already discussed why King H6 and
King H5 doesn't work so I figured the
only other idea is to block with a
knight if you try blocking with the Rook
instead this is a very ingenious idea
the problem is that White's gonna take
the Knight first and then take the Rook
okay so here white plays Bishop D5 and
everything hinges on this move B4 which
thrusts the game into complete and total
chaos and here I had to calculate a
certain line that at first sight may
seem to be only beneficial to White what
are the possibilities here for why our
opponent lost the game quickly with Rook
F7 that was a mistake what should white
do instead which pieces should white
take
well basically white has three candidate
moves okay what are White's three Canada
moves there's Bishop takes Knight
there's Bishop takes rook and there's
Bishop takes other Rook
Bishop takes Knight is really dumb
because you just take and at the end
white is down in exchange okay so that's
ruled out which Rook should white take
well white should actually take this
Rook
because if you take the other Rook
Black's gonna take the bishop
why is black gonna take the bishop black
is not going to take the Rook here
because that allows Bishop takes E5
check so we're going to take the bishop
White's gonna take the Rook we're gonna
take the rook and at the end the bishop
on A8 is terribly placed
King takes F1 loses the game to C2
compare that to the other capture
Bishop takes eight same thing happens BC
Bishop B4 Bishop F1 King F1 here the
bishop is optimally placed because C2 is
impossible but I saw this and I thought
that black is winning here with C takes
B2
now how do we assess this position well
what is black one black wants to get the
Knight over to A3 and promote the pawn
and win a piece and it turns out that
White's king is not fast enough because
white plays King E2 that's not the
beautiful part this all of this I saw
all of this I saw and look at this
position King D1 93 and you're
preventing the king from stopping the
pawn on the next move black promotes to
a queen and some technique is required
but black is in fact winning here
does that line makes sense to everybody
this line but here's the beautiful part
after King E2 Knight C4 white has an
only drawing move
incredible idea I've never seen quite
this idea before white to play and draw
the game again if you're watching on
YouTube I really think you should set
this up and take some time on this
because this is a high level exercise so
stronger players watching you really
would want to take some time on it yeah
one of one of you got it well Bishop B1
doesn't help right Bishop B1 doesn't do
anything it just makes it worse because
now I make this move a tempo
if you play Bishop C2 in King D3 I'm not
gonna take your Bishop I'm just gonna
promote
but hopefully you're you're spotting a
pattern which is your basic how do you
solve this well the basic premise the
basic idea is that
in the situation after black takes on B1
the Knight is essentially trapped and if
you keep calculating here you might find
that King C2 almost traps the Knight
here the Knight is able to escape but
only through B5 that's the only square
that the Knight is able to escape
through otherwise you would have to
repeat moves Forever Knight B1 King C2
Etc
so it's a prophylactic move that sets up
the drawing mechanism
A4 is correct
A4 Knight A3 now you walk the king over
black promotes you trade and with B5
under your control you're able to force
a repetition of moves
King B3
and Knight doesn't have B5 Knight has to
go back to B1 now knocking beatsu
because then the Knight escapes King C2
to keep the Knight confined and this is
a draw
and that's uh and that's how I could
have drawn the game
unbelievable so the line is in this
position
Bishop eight
BC Bishop E4 this is the easy part
King E2 or A4 by the way A4 even here is
good doesn't matter what the order is
but you can't forget to play for because
otherwise the Knight sits on A3 and your
Pawn is immobilized this is brilliant A4
drawing move
this absolutely should be used I'll use
this in some video because I'll
eventually do a book or a trustable
course like best moments from speedrun
series most instructive moments and this
is one of them this is unbelievable
might be one king C2 I hope you found
this as beautiful as I did
so Bishop a a could have drawn the game
but instead our opponent gives this
tempting check and now the problem is
that if white tries to do the same thing
right if white plays Bishop takes A8 now
well it's not gonna work anymore because
at the end of this line what's the
difference well the difference is the
bishop used to be on F1
here black is not making us be the one
to take the Rook with the king with the
bishop instead we're taking the Rook
with the King and white loses so our
opponent tried this move but we win the
game immediately with Knight F3 probably
the most resilient would have been to
play Bishop takes E4 check and Bishop
takes E5 this would have kept white in
the game because here white has a pawn
for the exchange but black is still
winning black is still winning not a
piece we are not winning a piece because
of this check but black should win this
with technique because the sender is
wide open and The Rook should Prevail in
this case
so this would have been the best chance
for
for black but uh for white but still um
okay we can't blame our opponent for
collapsing with the rookie seven I
almost missed Knight F3 check it's an
easy move to forget about
and that ladies and gentlemen is this
one of the most complicated games that
we have played I had a feeling that we
were going to get something good and we
did
so in conclusion G6 is a good move
against Knight C3 if you're an
accelerated player
then everything here was correct we
followed Theory now if you're a theory
junkie you can investigate E6 on your
own I'm not gonna do that in this video
just because I want to keep things at a
normal length the way we played was fine
our opponent played this very dangerous
Modern Line with T4 we responded to it
correctly by developing our pieces
Bishop B3 by the way is a nice move
um and the idea is to take the sting out
of the move D5 prophylaxis we responded
correctly with Knight A5 and B6 and this
is still Fury
this was our mistake Bishop A6 so the
Improvement is Bishop B7
then the Improvement for our opponent
would have been to play Bishop G5
and then of course the situation
remained very complicated he gave up a
piece here Bishop F2 would have kept an
unclear position
and then
fast forward all the way to the end
the beautiful draw with
Bishop takes A8 after B4
any questions any questions
okay you have said G6 and E6 is wrong
why not now so great question
um in previous speed runs I have claimed
that in the Sicilian you normally don't
want to combine the moves G6 and E6 that
is true I have claimed that but there is
a major caveat which is that
okay positionally it's quite dubious to
combine G6 and E6 but normally it all
relates to whether or not your opponent
can gain control of the D6 Square
okay in this position the D6 square is
under Black's control all right the D6
square is under blacks control but I
could also show you a situation where
black plays G6 and E6 and white is able
to stick
a queen on D6 or a knight on D6 or black
white is able to play E4 E5 and really
clamp down on that square that's when
you want to be very careful about
combining these two moves here's an
example of a game of mine I've shown
this game many times but I think it's
the best illustration of when not to
play E6 and G6
and this will hopefully give you a
little context on like the difference
between you know this game and
this game and situation where it's bad
to combine these two moves old game of
mine I managed to win this game but look
at what happens so my opponent plays A
Smith Laura I made the mistake of taking
at that point I had no idea what the
theory was so I decided to play G6
and here I decided to make a genius move
and play E6
so what is the chief difference between
this version and the version that we had
in our game well look at the fact that
white has a direct line of fire to the
D6 Square so he could have played Queen
D6 immediately but instead he starts
with Knight B5
and that's it already D6 is under
White's complete control
but instead of giving the check on D6
which a lot of people would have done he
plays Queen to D6 which wins the game
because Knight C7 is literally
Unstoppable you can't do anything about
that move I had to play Queen E7 and I
ended up losing a full Rook I win this
game because I ultimately end up winning
the Knight back and I also grabbed this
Pawn in the center so it's not that easy
to convert but you get the point
you get the point
it's it's all about whether the center
is open
also you have to be very careful
uh in a situation where white is able to
play the movie five and clamp down on
the D6 Square let me show you one more
example
of a very famous game the end of this
game is very famous the beginning not as
famous but still very instructive we
won't look at the whole game
I'll just show you the mistake that
black makes early on
okay here it is
so
this is a petrosion Pacman game which
ends with the famous Queen sacrifice
somewhat overrated combination to end
this game
but here's what Pac-Man does wrong in
the opening not David
ludek
so basically here Pac-Man plays D6 and
E6 which is fine but then he forgets to
play D6
here you have to play D6 he forgets to
do it and what does petrojan do
what does petroshan do
how does he punish Pacman for not
playing D6 he basically clamps down on
the dark squares yeah he plays E5
and it's not such a big issue black
plays D6 but this resulting position is
terrible because now black is like
this you know black structure is worse
and White's Knight is coming to E4 and
this Pawn is weak and the bishop is bad
so it would have been much much better
just to avoid all of this by playing D6
those are a couple of examples of when
you know black paid the price for
playing these two moves yeah this was uh
this was a bad game for black
and that's that we're going to conclude
here thank you for watching if you were
on YouTube
[Music]